climbing the world's tallest mountains
is a daring adventure but you're about
to make an epic
trek on the biggest mountain in the
entire solar system
how would this journey compare to
trekking the tallest peaks on earth
what kind of special equipment would you
need
and what would you see from the top
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you climbed the highest
mountain in the solar system
[Music]
behold olympus mons
this massive martian volcano is 25
kilometers high
making it the tallest mountain in the
entire solar system
the base of olympus mons covers about
the same amount of land as the state of
arizona and it's nearly three times
taller than mount everest climbing
everest is a grueling physical feat
you need to be in excellent physical
shape and spend weeks acclimatizing to
low oxygen levels at extreme altitudes
but thousands of people have reached the
summit of everest
could you be the first to reach the peak
of olympus mons
of course sometimes debt and interest
rates can reach heights as terrifying as
any peak in our solar system but with
upstart you can pay off your existing
debt with a personal loan and start
living your life again
that's why over 1 million people
worldwide are using upstart to create a
fixed monthly payment to clear off their
debts in just five minutes you can apply
for a personal loan tailored to your
needs
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
what if or click on the link in the
description below that's upstart.com
what if don't forget to use our url to
let them know we sent you
you can check your rate without
impacting your credit score in just five
minutes for loans between one thousand
and fifty thousand dollars loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application so go
to upstart.com
what if
now strap on your boots and grab a snack
getting over this mountain won't be as
easy as applying through upstart
let's not take for granted that to
attempt this climb
you'd have to make an arguably more epic
journey first
you'd have to get to mars
but assuming that worked
you'd arrive at the base of olympus mons
a giant moat would surround the mountain
because of the sheer weight of the
volcano
now would be a good time to be a good
mountaineer and check the weather
well fierce wind storms would likely be
raging all over the planet but with the
thin martian atmosphere
these winds wouldn't be as strong as on
earth
and there would be one other bonus
the atmosphere on mars is almost
entirely carbon dioxide
you'd have a space suit providing you
with a steady supply of oxygen so you
could breathe
and that means no need to adjust to the
oxygen levels at different altitudes on
the mountain
that's a lot different than on mount
everest where you'd have to worry about
the so-called death zone
this is the area higher than 7.9
kilometers
where oxygen levels are critically low
at the peak you'd only breathe one third
of the amount of oxygen you get at sea
level
your body could begin to break
down but you won't have to worry about
that on olympus mons
you could head straight to the peak with
a steady supply of oxygen
it would be best to have a smaller
device to convert carbon dioxide into
oxygen
otherwise your oxygen would be too bulky
to carry to the top
your journey from the base would start
with a cliff and not just any cliff
a nearly vertical cliff as tall as mount
everest
it could be seven to ten kilometers high
depending on where you are
if this first leg doesn't defeat you
the slope would be more gentle from here
on
you'd have about 30 hours of non-stop
hiking to reach the summit give or take
that is if nothing goes wrong on your
way
but at least that would be an almost
flat journey to the top
don't forget you're doing this in a
spacesuit that weighs around 38
kilograms
and that's taking into account that the
surface gravity of mars is about
one-third of earth's
imagine hiking everest with the same
suit
on earth it would weigh about 100
kilograms
the suit would have everything essential
to your survival all your oxygen food
and water
and you wouldn't be able to take it off
you'd have to eat food you could reach
with your mouth inside your helmet
nasa astronauts on space walks do this
with rice paper covered fruit and cereal
bars
and you'd need to eat in one bite
you wouldn't want crumbs flying around
your suit you'd need to carry your water
inside the suit too
or at least in a temperature controlled
backpack
water would freeze fast with the average
temperature on mars being minus 62
degrees
uh you'd also need to wear a thick fast
absorbing diaper to soak up your urine
but you're finally getting close to the
summit
you'd pass through thin wispy clouds of
water vapor this would surprise you
since it never rains on mars
at the top you'd encounter a massive
collapsed crater 85 kilometers wide
that's the width of lake ontario
with such a thin atmosphere around you
you'd feel like you're standing on an
island in space
a rust-colored sea stretching out all
around you
you made it
but now you'd have to get down and get
back to earth somehow
oops
you haven't figured that part out yet
have you
well hope you're ready to spend the next
100 years on mars
but
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]